Is the AfD far-right
and what does that actually mean
First of all we deal with the AfD
because the party has just n blatant run
and according to the last ARD Germany Trend
it is even second strongest party in the survey
What is the current stand
So the AfD
is described by the Office for the
Protection of the Constitution as an extremist
Suspicion case observed
In contrast,
the party appealed 1
Currently there is 1 more procedure for this reason
in front of theOberverwaltungsgericht in Münster
At the presentation of the current
verfassungsschutzberichts 2022
In June
said the President of the Office for the
Protection of the Constitution Thomas Heidenberg
that in the AfD
about 10,200 people
with extremist potential are
That's more than 1/3 of the nearly 30,000 party members
Moreover,
that anti-Semitic stance in the AfD
are very widespread
and 1 majority of the members of Russia
is influenced
What does right-wing extremist in general mean
According to the Amadeu Antonio Foundation,
right-wing is
1 generic term for all political attitudes
that democracy
and reject the of all people
Therefore,
1 important component of the ideology
that one's own nation
is found to be better for higher value